however always good to talk with your
buddy a lot to get into I guess I want
to start with the McDaniels thing I
don't know if you heard what I was
saying but I feel like the combination
of whatever happened with the Colts last
year and Tebow I feel like those would
be my first two questions if I was
interviewing him and I feel like that
might be that might be tough for him to
overcome well you know I I think I take
it back further than that back to a
former teammate of yours and I think a
lot of people that were in New England
in 2008 for the Matt Cassel year really
got this idea like we can do this with
whatever quarterbacks like we can do
that it doesn't matter who you give us
just give me an athlete who can think
through and who can learn and I'll be
able to take something with it you know
and so I think whoever the guys that
were there in the offensive side of the
ball in 2000 and I think Bill O'Brien
was affected by this too you just see
what's the way that they fumble through
quarterbacks are used in the first few
years but they could almost make do with
anything a quarterback and I think josh
has learned his lesson on that and so
you know I I think he's a very different
coats than he was in Denver and it's a
problem that he has from a perception
standpoint is that you know he left
Denver goes to st. Louis for a year that
doesn't work out they all get fired and
then he goes back to New England and
he's with the greatest quarterback of
all time again but I can tell you the
way the teams look at him and the way
the teams that are considering him look
at him is as somebody who was way ahead
when it comes all the offensive
innovation that we've seen over the
course of the last you know like three
four years and all the college concepts
making their way to the NFL and all of
that like josh mcdaniels has really seen
as somebody who was on the front end of
that and I could certainly see where a
team like Green Bay would be very very
interested if they saw his experience
with Tom Brady do you think Albert that
he's the most highly sought after
candidate and if he's not is there a guy
that you hear or believe is is hotter
than anybody else well I first of all no
I don't think I don't think gosh this
everybody and one of the reasons why I
think that Green Bay is might wind up
being the right fit and and I think
Green Bay is the work that very
seriously you can look at like a week
from now it could be making that higher
one there's you know some pre-existing
background with him and a general
manager in that he was the front runner
for the 49ers job three years ago or two
years ago and simultaneously Brian
gudykunst the guy whose Packers general
manager now with the for the 49ers GM
Jeff so they didn't work on each other
on the second piece is that the Packers
need to find someone who can coach Aaron
Rodgers I know that sounds like a simple
thing but how many people on the planet
can possibly know what it's like to have
to find a way to give Aaron Rodgers new
information to challenge him on a
day-to-day basis and how difficult that
is well you know josh mcdaniels because
he's coached Tom Brady is one of the few
people who has experience doing that
sort of thing was that level of
quarterback I do not think he's the most
sought after candidate and I'm gonna
tell you that I cook the most sought
after candidate right now
has a job and will be coaching this
weekend and that's John Harbaugh and I
just I just tell you that I think a lot
of teams are sitting out there waiting
to see what happens and if he doesn't
send an extension and a lot of this is
gonna come down to timing Ross you know
that like if they make a run to the AFC
Championship game one of these teams are
gonna have to move on but if they get
eliminated this weekend there's gonna be
a handful of teams that are gonna be
sitting there and saying that's why you
can see whether or not John Harbaugh
does that extension with the rapist so
there are some moving pieces there and
again you know I think because the
turnover over the last eight years and
sort of the pipeline there are a lot of
teams that feel like this year in
particular they've gotta think outside
the box think creatively about who's
gonna hire but even if he doesn't sign
an extension Albert he's still under
contract through next year right but if
you're the Ravens and you know he
doesn't want to be there and I'm not
saying that's a game so let's just say
John Harbaugh looks at it as Ozzie
Newsome is gone there's you know a new
general manager coming in and Eric the
cost for the organization is going to be
a little different I say he wants a
little more control and he can't get it
do the Ravens then go forward knowing
that that very well might be John
Harbaugh's next year do they go forward
with John Harbaugh and a lame duck here
or do they turn around and try to get
draft pick form I mean I think that's
the question right like is to you if
you're the Ravens you know and here in
that situation and he's not willing to
sign an extension and you know that you
might lose him in a year is it better to
go through with the 2019 season with him
as your coach knowing that you know he
might be gone or is it better to rip the
band-aid off and collect some some some
conversation for him I think it's a fair
question to ask talking to Albert brewer
my buddy from the mm QB you can catch
him as well NBC Sports Boston he always
has the information terrific point about
McDaniels and Aaron Rodgers and and with
how close Rogers and Brady are I do
think that there would be you know that
Rodgers would you know not that he's the
one making the decision but he
definitely would sign off on it and be
happy about it I would imagine yeah and
you know it's again it's a challenge to
coach those guys I think that anybody
who coached Peyton Manning will tell you
the same thing that there's an anxiety
that comes along with coaching guys at
that level you know you know a
day-to-day basis are so prepared and
there's got so much background and
they've got so much experience and you
know they they know the game so well
there's very very difficult to find some
prefer a coach on a day to day basis to
go in that environment and know like
this guy's gonna think I'm full of it
I'm right I'm not working him and you
know that's how games made his name
Peyton Manning was that you know field
text from Peyton at 1:00 in the morning
of Peyton had a something he needed
answer you know and so you know that
piece of it I think is really really
important and I think Tom Brady would
communicate that to Aaron Rodgers which
would be huge for Josh going in going in
there and knowing that that's been
communicated to Aaron Rodgers Aaron's
not the easiest guy to coach Aaron has
his own sack on the way that things
should be I think that the guys are mike
mccarthy staff would tell you that you
know
Aaron's propensity for changing plays
and playing hopscotch knowing all that
different stuff
frustrated Emma points and made it made
it more difficult for her McCarthy and
his assistants as play callers but I
would tell you the flip side of that is
that you know where all the little
problems he's had the philosophy or the
frustrations that he's had with
McCarthy's offense I would think that
he'd have to be open-minded to someone
with Josh McDaniels resume coming in and
trying to put the offense on a different
level in its bed okay so Albert put a
hardball aside since he's under contract
is there a guy who's available right now
that's the most you know intriguing guy
or the people is it Adam GaSe is there
is there a guy that you who are you most
convinced is gonna get a job
I take cases in that group you know I
think cases there and gay say to me it's
just you know combination of okay he's
got head coaching experience he's got
the most out of the quarterbacks he's
been around and you know I think that
he'll get in the interview room that
impressed people so he's definitely one
I'm gonna give you another one that's
sort of off the radar that I believe
could have can't have a job if he wants
one and that's the the that's the head
coach at Iowa State Matt Campbell
telling us a general manager put him on
my radar in September and the amount of
unsolicited tax I get from people in the
league whenever I write or say something
about Matt Campbell is staggering about
how impressive he is how impressive the
program at Iowa State is their questions
of course coming from the college level
about you know how would he put a staff
together what would it look like all the
rest of it but you know I very much
think that you know I said that if he
were willing to talk to the Jets I think
he would be at or near the top of their
list and I think that the Browns quietly
quietly see if they keep see if you see
where his interest is and and maybe
quietly go in and talk to him you know
these things obviously if the college
level have to be a little bit different
because of how they were correct affects
recruiting and all the rest of it but I
think Matt Campbell will be a head coach
in the NFL in the next year or two if he
doesn't go to McCall
look like alright so Albert we talked
about the first two questions I would
ask josh mcdaniels I want to get to Adam
GaSe then because I've seen you tweet
that things didn't end well in Denver
which is why he's not a candidate
they're the Miami Dolphins just fired
him I thought somewhat surprisingly and
reportedly there were players that went
to the owner Steven Ross and said that
they wanted him out they didn't like him
I mean I mean my first question if I'm
interviewing Adam cases what the heck
happened in Denver in Miami that things
ended so poorly yeah I would just tell
you in Denver it's I don't know who was
the Broncos being I picked off at him as
much as it was maybe him being ticked
off that he wasn't more of a candidate I
mean bring up an ED coaching job there
when I went to Gary Kubiak and that all
happened really really quick and because
you know part of the condition of Kubiak
calming was that he got to bring Rick
Dennis and his offensive coordinator
there just wasn't a spot for him in
Denver
now in 2015 and so I think that there's
I'd be surprised if Denver went that
route based on everything there as for
you know you know how he's gonna explain
away what happened you know Miami what
happened to Denver you know look III
think that he's absolutely positively
from you know that Nick Saban Bill
Belichick school of coaching because
this guy's hard he's tough he comes off
as an alpha and he's not for everybody
but I think you can see the players who
listen Dylan got results
now the question with Adam GaSe is going
to be how comfortable are you with you
know him having a strong idea and what
he wants and players because there are
obviously some guys in that that were in
Miami that aren't my am anymore because
you know gays didn't want guys a kendama
can sue and Jarvis Landry the only they
want to program guys and so they wound
up being on and so you know you have to
be comfortable with that part of it but
I think the results he's got in getting
the most guys who sign up for what he's
selling them has to have been I was
standing almost across the board
he's got he got a lot out of a Miami
team this year that wasn't very talented
and you know so I think there's a lot of
positive there on top of the obvious
which is that he's a still a young guy
who's got a lot of experience coaching
quarterbacks is a very very out Albert
whoa what are the eight openings was the
most surprising to you was a case was it
Mike Brown finally pulling the trigger
on Marvin Lewis and do you think that
there might be any more surprises to
come Jay Gruden or elsewhere no I mean I
think this is probably it was the
possible exception you know with a
possible that the possible exception of
Baltimore you know like where you know
something happens there I don't think
the owner
I still think Steve bisciotti you know I
think he's being horrible like I think
that that is a big part of what happened
in Baltimore was we started looking out
at the landscape and recognizing like
holy crap like all these teams are
lining up climbing up to to hire my
coach and I'm looking out at the
landscape like and I'm an ayah who
instead of John Harbaugh like oh we tap
the brakes here and so I think bisciotti
very I think Michelle he's genuine when
he says they want to hold on to her
about the surprising one of me was
probably I would say the fact that Miami
did what they did surprise me a little
bit just in that I knew Tannenbaum and
gates wouldn't be back together and I
thought there was a chance that it was
going to be Jason Greer running the show
there I'm surprised that they went the
route that they went and I think it's an
intelligent way to do it I think Chris
Greer was growing up in the room a lot
of times there and among those the guys
in that building maybe the most
respected across the league I was
surprised that you know getting rid of
gays and getting rid of Tannenbaum
didn't we do a total bulb in Miami and I
think it's actually that's actually
wrong too you know I think at least was
able to see this in a rational way and
recognize that Chris Greer was a guy who
was very very capable of leading a team
even though he hadn't done it before
always appreciate the time thank you so
much
excellent insight information as well
encourage people to check you out on
Twitter at Albert Breuer and all the
stuff you're writing over the mmq b it
is fantastic thanks so much man
all right there he is Albert Breer my
buddy from the mmq bead forum or Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]